Germans love their boardgames and an absolute
classic is "Fang den Hut" or "Catch the hat."
Teams of little hats move around the board
trying to catch one other –
or the special golden hat.
But today we're putting a political twist
on this family favorite and playing "Catch
the voter."
Here are our parties, raring to go, ready
for the race to parliament.
They stretch from the far left of the political
spectrum to the far right, and they're all
trying to get our voter to support them.
But who is this voter, and what do they want
from the parties?
All German citizens over the age of 18 can
vote in federal elections.
That's a total of 60.4 million people, just
over half of whom are women.
It's a pretty multicultural group, with almost
a third having at least one parent who was
born in another country.
One of the most interesting aspects is age.
Less than 15% of the voting population are
younger than 30.
Nearly 40% are over 60, and half of those
are over 70.
It also matters where the voters are.
Germany's cities and regions have strong local
identities.
Their priorities are affected by things like
the local economy, infrastructure and even
religion.
Some of the issues on voters' minds are very
much signs of the times.
No prizes in this game for guessing that the
COVID-19 pandemic is right up there.
In Germany, the regional state authorities
have a lot of decision-making power in areas
like health and education.
During the pandemic, this led to a patchwork
of different rules across the country.
But what do voters want to see done at the
federal level?
The next government should dedicate itself
to problems that have been highlighted by
the pandemic, such as faltering digitalization.
First is, ensure full immunization of the
complete population in Germany.
Second is no more lockdowns.
I want my future government to restore my
freedom.
We have to be prepared.
If there's a mutation, we have to be prepared
to answer to that as quickly as possible.
Next up, climate change – a topic that's
difficult to ignore after the deadly floods
in Germany this summer.
In a recent survey more than 80% of participants
said they want to see urgent action on climate
protection – a view shared across generational
and party lines.
Natural catastrophes were always really far
away, but at the moment they're right on our
doorstep.
It feels like the whole world is burning right
now.
I think we need an earlier coal phase-out
and instead invest in more renewable energy.
I hope the next government interferes more
in our daily lives, so that we understand
that things can't go on like this.
You need to propose solutions for all the
cuts you're going to make to social lives
and industry.
Immigration & foreign policy have of course
been huge topics in Germany in recent years,
and they're back in focus following recent
developments in Afghanistan.
This is one area that polarizes voters, and
it has pushed some away from the larger centrist
parties.
When it comes to refugees, Germany clearly
needs more regulation, checks and, if necessary,
deportations.
We need workers and these people need somewhere
to live.
Especially if you consider that Germany played
a role in the reason why many of these people
had to flee in the first place.
I also think that the EU needs to find more
solutions for sharing the load fairly between
the countries.
Issues which always feature heavily include
education, the economy and jobs, security,
and the distant dream of digitalization.
And remember all those over-60s voters?
Their voting power is clear in the prominence
of "Rentenpolitik" or pension policy in the
party manifestos.
Germany hasn't yet jumped on the worldwide
trend towards personality-driven politics.
Once again in this year's line-up of chancellor
candidates, there's no sign of a larger-than-life
maverick, or celebrity-turned-politician.
But in any case, voters here don't directly
elect the Chancellor.
They vote for members of parliament – and
they're the ones who'll decide who gets Angela
Merkel's old job.
Each voter does, however, have two votes – one
for a local candidate and one for a party
on the national level.
This means they could vote tactically for
two different parties, focusing on local issues
with their first vote and ideological interest
with the second.
In the last election in 2017, a quarter of
voters split their ballots in this way.
While TV is still the main source of information
for most Germans, the switch to digital platforms
has begun, with smaller parties, especially
on the right, having made the most ground
so far.
Some of the larger parties are trying to catch
up on Facebook, hoping to bag themselves some
boomers.
But they've also begun to make a play for
younger voters on platforms like TikTok – with
varying degrees of success and plenty of cringe.
So, on September 26th it's time to roll the
dice again.
Which groups will have the biggest turnout
– men or women, young or old?
People in the east or west, or people in the
cities or in the countryside?
And what will going through their minds in
the voting booth – will it be migration?
Jobs?
Climate?
Or simply the faces of the top candidates?
It's all to play for in the 2021 finale of
"Catch the voter."